wir sind heute eingeladen bei familie
regierung in bytom
im süden polens die familie lernt
deutsch mit german heute kochen wir
schlesische rouladen philipp zeigt uns
heute wie man rouladen macht bleiben
sind ein typisch chinesisches gericht
aber sie sind auch ein typisch deutsches
gericht als erstes stellen wir euch die
zu tagen vor
das ist speck das sind würstchen
das sind zwiebeln und das ist eine saure
gurke jetzt zeigt uns philipp wie man
rouladen macht philipp gloggner fleisch
mit einem fleischklopfer flach das ist
ein fleischklopfer jetzt wird das
fleisch gesalzen und gepfeffert
als nächstes mit philipp den senf und
streicht den vans auf das rindfleisch
jetzt wird die gurke geschnitten
philipp schneidet die gurke in streifen
aber philipp hat sich geschnitten
schnell wir brauchen einen schlachter
während philipp verachtet wird schneidet
caccia die gurken streifen in kleine
würfel
jetzt wird der speck in würfel
geschnitten die speckwürfel kommen auch
auf das rindfleisch katja schneidet die
zwiebel klein
die zwiebelwürfel kommen auch auf das
rindfleisch
jetzt wird die roulade gerollt die
rollade wird gerollt und mit einem faden
zusammengeschnürt der faden wird um das
fleisch gewickelt und erhält das fleisch
zusammen um die roulade zusammen zu
schnüren kann man jede art von
natürlichem wind farben nehmen zum
beispiel aus baumwolle die erste roulade
ist jetzt fertig als nächstes kommt die
roulade in die pfanne
zuerst gibt kasse etwas butter in die
pfanne und die fahne wird vorgeheizt zu
der butter kommt auch noch öl in die
pfanne sascha link die roulade in die
pfanne
sie wird in der pfanne erstmal
angebraten zu den rouladen gibt es heute
schlesische größe diese größe werden aus
kartoffeln und kartoffelmehl gemacht
sie sind ein typisch traditionelles
chinesisches gericht
[Musik]
was passiert jetzt die roulade ist von
außen schon angebraten
aber jetzt warten wir darauf dass das
wasser kocht
jetzt wird die roulade in wasser gelegt
indem wasser wird die roulade
die roulade muss mindestens zwei stunden
garen
da das sehr lange dauert haben wir schon
eine fertige roulade vorbereitet guck
mal janisch das ist eine fertige roulade
mit soße das wasser kocht
jetzt kann kasse die klöße kochen
die klöße werden in das heiße wasser
gegeben
dann müssen sie einige minuten kochen
wenn die klöße oben schwimmen müssen sie
noch zwei minuten ziehen
jetzt kann kascha die klöße aus dem
wasser nehmen sind die klöße fertig fand
ich sehr gut
kuka steckt den tisch janus schreibt
sich schon den bauch das essen ist
fertig von der tisch ist gedeckt jetzt
probieren wir die rouladen die klöße und
den rotkohl
danke für eure einladung jetzt probiert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hmm
flecken
schmidt
wir haben uns die roulade sich
vorzüglich